Diann it's 9:15 a.m. the donuts are
fresh in the sun shining which means as
locals like to say around here I'm as
happy as a clam at high water on a
Sunday this morning I woke up to a
curious note under my bedroom door it
read the fat man who tore down the wall
wants to know wants to know what who is
that man let's investigate
Diane once again struck by the
realization that all of us on this
planet earth only understand a fraction
of what's going on around us that's why
I'm employing a unique investigative
strategy that relies both on ancient
Tibetan practices and intuition chance
will be our guide I'll read the name and
then I'll throw the rock mark frost TV
writer David Lynch director Oh Brad
Dukes
author let's call it Brad Dukes rub this
book reflections in oral history of Twin
Peaks operator get me Brad dukes Brad do
you hear me
coupe is that you no time for
pleasantries brat
I received a note under my door it read
the fat man who tore down the wall wants
to know what does he want to know who
killed Laura Palmer it was Bob spirit
Leland's body we know no that's what the
note says the fat man wants to know who
killed Laura call Jules time of its
spelling entertainment he will know
thanks Brad operator give me Jules time
of its TV exec Jules I received a note
this morning whose contents you might
have the key to deciphering okay it read
the fat man who tore down the wall wants
to know I believe it's in reference to
Laura Palmer yes I was told Louis Bobby
the Gorbachev had get called into our
and Spellings office Aaron Spelling the
TV execs I guess the question who killed
Laura Palmer is there important you said
yes one background said I can't get an
answer and I said who wants to know
maybe that'll help me then he proceeded
to tell me a story that called Linda
Acharya shareholder at that point of
spelling entertainment so had received a
call from George Bush who in turn had
received a call from
gova Club Gorbachov the eighth and final
leader of the Soviet Union what did you
want to know we got a request from
Gorbachev wanting to know who killed
Laura on them
thanks Jules chili by now that that
mandatory on the wall knows the answer
you
[Music]